hey Steve you're the Eddie Van Halen
dude you're the expert I think Wolfgang
is an excellent guitar player when I saw
him doing where was it it was at the Foo
Fighters tribute to Taylor Hawkins I
believe if I got that wrong you tell me
yeah they did two of them there was one
in uh Wembley in London and then one in
LA and he was just [ __ ] incredible on
guitar like so amazing like he he nailed
what Eddie did but he didn't do it note
for note like he played in the way that
Eddie would play Live which is not note
for note with the record
it was a perfect tribute to his dad the
kids got massive Talent
because that's like the way Eddie would
do especially when he opened uh for Hot
for Teacher on the on the record for the
start of Hot for Teacher Eddie does a
pick slide which is like
but what Eddie would always do live and
what Wolfgang did live was this little
trick where he goes
before he went into the Riff and I was
like oh that is just so perfect do you
ever come up with your own original
riffs
yeah I got this one riff I love right
now uh hold on I gotta switch guitars
real quick I'll show you but it's fun
Springsteen exactly switch guitar
tuning Man by the way this interview
with Steve nowicki will be on HBO
minimum not Max
this is the Riff I was working on the
other day
[Music]
jamming
[Music]
I am
Jimmy
[Music]
rock is alive
rocking dead
jamming with no Wicked don't [ __ ] with
my head
[Music]
what's up
damn we're good
yeah come on man did you hear my vocals
you should go right to the Rock and Roll
Hall of Fame you came up with a band
name I think it was earlier this year
took us and I'm like I really want to
start a band with you called took us
you're the lead singer I I think we'd be
awesome and you get some Superstars
you got to say it right it's tokis
Turkish in concert
[Music]
[Laughter]
okay
yes there are new hit songs smell my
took us
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
ing deep ends amen
[ __ ] we're good this is what I've been
waiting for I only write when I have
something to say and smell my touch
isn't exactly what I want to sell let's
go to the bridge here we go
it's
dark it's dirty it's talking
yeah that's the sound
you're hearing a band at work oh yeah
we're working on a new song right here
in front of the audience
[Music]
you're gonna puke but I don't care
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
that's the signature of took a sound
yeah no hooks that's it